uh a significant development now i i
thought it was
huge earlier this year when the nfl took
the packers colts game and moved it to 4
25 p.m eastern on a sunday when cowboys
at vikings was due to be the marquee
late afternoon 4 25 pm kickoff yeah that
that is one kind of that's kind of the
the old glove slap in the face you know
how they used to do the gloves they
wouldn't slap you they take the glove
off and they'd hit you with the glove
like who's that going to hurt this is
the full-blown
round slap like yeah like this is the
older
who was the the jaguars guy that used to
get hit in the face before marc john or
john henderson right john henderson yes
that's what this is because
the cowboys
have been flexed out
of prime time
sunday night football cowboys 49ers are
you kidding me they're gone brown's
giants
is installed as the sunday night game
for week 15. cowboys had never been
flexed out of sunday night football
that's the team everyone wants you want
the cowboys the cowboys bring the
numbers the cowboys bring the interest
the cowboys bring the eyeballs not this
year and and i remember asking stephen
jones within the past two years how is
it that this team continues to and i did
it in a very
positive way it wasn't like gee you guys
stink why does anyone watch you it was
how is it that you've managed to
continue this mystique and this draw in
this attraction when when when the the
results haven't matched it
and well this year they haven't been
able to maintain the mystique in the
attraction in the draw because they got
flexed out of prime time for the browns
and the giants chris yeah i mean you
know i mean i'm glad that's all i can
really say i mean that's that's the
first thing i don't want dallas
i i mean is arguably the worst watch in
football right now they're they're
they're up there i mean i'm dead serious
i i there's a there's a part of me that
i think would rather watch the jets play
than the dallas cowboys in a lot of ways
and i know there's especially if they're
going to go zero blitz well yeah
absolutely it's great great theater
always well and the cowboys of course
were trying to do their own stupid stuff
early in the year too to make great
theater as well but i i mean i get it
you know what what what's the first off
the 49ers they're not what they you know
were last year they're on they're
teetering on they really can't even make
one more mistake or they're done and
even if they don't make that mistake
they're gonna have to hope other teams
make some mistakes here and then dallas
yeah andy dalton and the cowboys on
sunday night football i mean no negative
ghost rider i mean cleveland is
intriguing right now cleveland has
officially
entered the cream of the crop of the nfl
and they have star power and it's a good
city you know it's got great fan base
and these are old powers of the nfl and
the giants have a little bit of intrigue
here too you know people might not know
a lot of their players but i think a lot
of the national media is a little bit
like whoa the giants and joe judge they
they got what are they doing they kind
of got something good going on here so
i'm very excited that we have made that
move here at nbc and i think it'll be a
far better football game and better to
watch and everything and again it's the
nfl's decision it's not nbc's decision
the nfl decides which games are best
suited to the primetime audience and
this is a gift from the nfl a
pre-christmas gift from the nfl to the
football fan that may be watching on
sunday night the the week 15 which would
be what is it december 20 i think it is
right that that game is uh is going to
be a better game now because the browns
are a contender the giants are a
contender hey yeah that colt mccoy may
still be playing quarterback
for i hope not and
and there's a there's a hey there's a
neat little revenge angle because who
did colt mccoy first play for he played
for the cleveland browns i kind of like
the the symmetry there there's a lot of
stuff there's a lot the how about the
odell beckham jr trade a lot of these
guys on the giants no he's not playing i
know but still there's business here you
know where the giants have got jabril
peppers and kevin zeitler who are very
good players for their team from the
browns and that and yeah odell's not
playing there's also the angle of let's
not forget what did baker mayfield say
about daniel jones before the draft last
year we had a call yes oh
that could be fun to watch too you know
so that's why i want daniel jones back
no disrespect to colt mccoy hook horns
buddy but yeah i want to see that aspect
of that too let alone man giants browns
that's like i don't know that just rings
1958 to me it's kind of old school and i
like it it might be the last time these
two teams were good where it means
something so uh i'm all for watching
this on sunday night football
yeah i i really
agree with you and i probably would
prefer daniel jones to be back for that
game they are optimistic he'll play this
week against the cardinals i still
don't know how you come back from that
that hamstring that was aggravated when
they put him back in the game the day
that the injury happened against the
bengals i don't know how you come back
from it in only two weeks but we'll see
they've got they've got all sorts of
medical techniques and devices available
although i know you you strongly believe
that they're not as good as they could
be with some of the technologies they
use to get players back but but who
knows we'll find out it's still a week
and a couple of days away before we see
the giants and the browns get together
mike mccarthy the cowboys coach
addressed this yesterday being flexed
out of prime time these are the types of
things that i guess happen when you're
not successful we're disappointed make
no bones about it well they should be
disappointed because this is more than
just you're having a bad year because
the cowboys have had bad years over the
past 25 seasons they haven't been back
to the nfc championship game since the
last time they won a super bowl it is
the cowboys washington and detroit the
only three teams in the nfc that haven't
played in an nfc championship game since
the 1995 season that is embarrassing
but the cowboys still up until this year
had that that aura and now it's gone and
and look it'll be back next year if they
keep that prescott doesn't this play to
dak prescott's advantage yeah chris
does
well yeah because because you've got a
guy who who had resonated with fans
exactly the fans love and if anything
they love him more after what he endured
earlier this year when he broke his leg
broke his ankle
uh this this this is this is even more
money flowing as it rightfully should in
the direction of dak prescott because
they need him to get their shine back
well yeah he's it's like a double whammy
with the shine too it's like one
okay dallas is obviously better but doc
press got a quarterback and dak prescott
i know they weren't winning a ton of
games when he was there healthy but holy
cow they were a lot more competitive and
he gave you the he gave you the chance
in every game where even though you went
oh their defense stinks and this isn't
going well well prescott and these
receivers he'll he'll he'll make plays
and they'll stay in it i mean dak
prescott again
i think we all undervalued maybe his
importance to that football team and how
good he is it's not sexy and you know
highlight and like sidearm throws and no
look throws and just so so it's maybe
not as intriguing to fans in the media
and everything that way but the results
are effective and then mike like to what
you're saying at least he's a a face of
the franchise type guy he is a guy that
i think you know
yeah he he adds something to the lure of
the the the show in which uh which is
the dallas cowboys you know handsome
black guy you know
is just good leader charismatic awesome
on commercials does everything
professional all that so he adds to that
aspect of them too to where yeah if it
was him you know and three and eight
football team
it's it's like oh okay i could watch
this this is kind of fun even though
they're not good i know he's gonna put
on a good show and make some things
happen here uh but without him you're
right it's it's a boring story and
there's nothing really i'm excited to
turn in tune in and watch with dallas
right now
they need him back next year they
definitely need him back there's a
question about the coaching staff a
point shireen williams made yesterday on
pftpm
that
mike nolan the defensive coordinator
could be in serious serious jeopardy
stephen jones made a comment on radio
that hey you know the guys who are
struggling this year to stop the run are
the same guys last year who were able to
stop the run yeah in other words it
ain't them right it's and and this this
is a tension that we spotted weeks ago
because for most teams the coaching
staff and the general manager right you
have that well are you getting the right
players as the gm and as the coaching
staff are you coaching up the guys that
we've given you
in dallas the gm
is jones and jones it's stephen and it's
jerry and they're the ones picking these
players so the coaching staff is always
going to lose that argument and look i
don't
i don't believe that they would
fire mike mccarthy after one year i
think mike nolan's out i don't think
they'd fire mike mccarthy after one year
because they know that in a roundabout
way
and it's not all that roundabout
that they'd be admitting that they made
a huge mistake hiring him they kind of
fell in love with him in one meeting and
they rushed to make the decision
but
you know i i that well that was before
they got flexed out of sunday night
football i i can't help but wonder
whether or not getting flexed out of
sunday night football changes the
analysis about whether or not they
should just press the reset button after
this season i'm with you i mean mike
nolan i understand that i do you know
listen i'm a mike nolan fan i am you
know there's a lot of blame to go there
as you know that right i mean we talked
about this why did you hire mike nolan
you know he doesn't play the defense
that fits what your defense from last
year did that makes no sense you could
also look at mike nolan and go well hey
i know this is not what you do but your
t your players can't do what you want in
your defense so how about we revert back
to a little bit of what we did last year
and play that style so there's a little
bit of both to go around there i think
more blame goes on the jones family and
just the thought there of why bring a
guy in that runs a different defense
that doesn't fit your personnel scheme
that does not make sense so uh but i
understand the blame for mike nolan and
it's been a bad look and i mean it's
just obvious now and all of that the
mccarthy thing i'm with you i don't
i don't think they're one to
fire after a year they believe it i
think they are smart enough to know you
got to build something but also it looks
bad on them to make a switch that
quickly it shows that they were
egregiously wrong and it was more than
just the results on the field and
injuries that you know dishearten them
or make that move to fire him if they
did so i i i think mccarthy will be back
as well but
with the way this year has gone and if
it doesn't end well he's going to be
already on the next year going into year
two where you're gonna go okay this is
it it's a make or break year he's on the
hot seat already in year two of his
coaching career here in dallas
there's another wrinkle to this and this
is something that shireen williams who
covered the cowboys for years before she
joined us a few years back pointed out
when we were talking earlier in the year
about is mccarthy in trouble
jerry jones on the surface has nothing
in common with mike brown the owner of
the cincinnati bengals
however at a certain level they have one
thing in common they are both extremely
careful with money
jerry jones is not going to want to pay
mike mccarthy for multiple years to not
coach the cowboys when did jason garrett
finally get fired when his contract
expired right
no buyout for jason garrett well so
so so that that's a factor in this as
well the idea that you would be paying
you would be rewarding financially mike
mccarthy to go away and not be your head
coach and that may be something that
jerry jones doesn't want to do i think
the bigger factor though is just the the
admission that you screwed up you know
and look what are the best what are the
best football teams do when they make a
mistake the best organizations admit the
mistake
and move on but sometimes you do get too
much of the ego tied up in it and you're
not willing to admit the mistake chris
no yeah you're you're right um
also if it was a mistake and maybe maybe
it wasn't maybe it wasn't i'll tell you
what
this this season
i i i i look back at my predictions
going in and i'm i'm i'm i'm not
too proud to admit this i had the
cowboys the one seed what was i drinking
that day you're not alone there's a lot
of people i mean i think i picked the
cowboys to go into the into the playoffs
too i mean i so
i i don't think you're crazy i can name
a few people who picked the cowboys to
go to the super bowl too and nfl media
and things like that too so
i don't think that was like out of this
world um to think that before the year
especially when we don't get to see
preseason football or do anything like
that you know you think they're going to
carry over a little what they had last
year we never envisioned their defense
was going to fall apart like this
we didn't think dak prescott was gonna
get hurt and all of that as well
um so and we were excited about their
offensive weapons i i mean i i don't i
think i i understand those thoughts mike
i i do
and you know even saying all that i mean
they had chances early on in the year
you know to do a lot of different things
i mean game was mismanaged you know with
the rams the seahawks game they had a
chance there of course cleveland we know
they had a chance in that football game
too i mean there's there's plenty of
opportunities where they could have
righted the ship to be respectful but
they didn't uh but i'm with you i don't
think they make that type of change with
mccarthy unless
unless these last few weeks just became
an absolute debacle and then maybe they
go back to the drawing bar but i have a
hard time believing that
well you could argue it's been a debacle
lately it was a debacle against the
ravens it was definitely a debacle
against washington losing at home in
front of 30 million people watching on
tv and that's what makes that flex out
so stunning they drew 30 million people
to watch them play and lose to
washington on thanksgiving but look i i
think that spot is going to draw 30
minutes just about no matter which team
this year pandemic everyone's starving
for anything to do like i i you're right
they they could have put on just about
any game and i think it would have got
pretty damn high ratings
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports